when I received the Nobel
I got to what
exactly how much
was related to literature I want
to reflect on it and see where the
connection was I'm going to try to
articulate that to you and most likely
it will go in a roundabout way but I
hope what I say will be worthwhile and
purposeful if I was to go back to the
donning of it all I guess I'd have to
start with Buddy Holly Buddy died when I
was about 18 he was 22 from the moment I
first heard him I felt a kin
I felt related like he was an older
brother I even thought of resembling him
but he played the music that I loved the
music I grew up on
country-western rock and roll and rhythm
and blues three separate strands of
music that he intertwined and infused
into one genre one brand and Buddy wrote
songs songs that had beautiful melodies
and the imaginative verses and he sang
great sang in more than a few voices he
was the archetype everything I wasn't
and wanted to be
I saw him only but once and that was a
few days before he was gone I had to
travel a hundred miles to get to see him
play and it wasn't disappointed he was
powerful and electrifying
and had a commanding presence I was only
six feet away
he was mesmerizing I watched his face
his hands lady kept his foot his big
black glasses the eyes behind the
glasses the way he held his guitar the
way he stood his neat suit
everything about him he looked older
than 22 something about him seemed
permanent and he filled me with
conviction then out of the blue the most
uncanny thing happened he looked me
right straight in the eye and he
transmitted something something I didn't
know what and it gave me the chills I
think it was a day or two after that
with his plane went down and somebody
somebody had never seen before and it be
a liberal record with the song cotton
fields on it and ever I could change my
life right then and there
transported me into a world I'd never
known it was like an explosion went off
like I've been walking in darkness and
all of a sudden that darkness was
illuminated it was like somebody laid
hands on me I must have played that
record a hundred times it was on a label
I'd never heard of with a booklet inside
with advertisements for other artists on
a label
Sonny Terry and brownie McGhee the new
Lost City Ramblers
Jean Ritchie string bands I'd never
heard any of them but I reckoned if they
were on this label with red belly they
had to be good so I needed to hear them
I wanted to know all about it and play
that kind of music I still had that
feeling for the music I'd grown up with
but for right now I forgot about it
good name was think about it for the
time being it was long gone I hadn't
left home yet but I couldn't wait to I
wanted to learn this music and meet the
people who played it eventually I did
leave and I did learn to play those
songs they were difference in the radio
songs that I'd been listening to all
along they were more vibrant and
truthful to life with radio songs a
performer might get a hit by the roll of
his eyes or follow the cards but that
didn't matter in the folk world
everything was a hit all you had to do
is be well-versed to be able to play the
melody some of these songs were easy
some not that a natural feeling for the
ancient ballads in country blues but
everything else had to learn from
scratch and I was playing for small
crowds sometimes no more than four or
five people in a room or a street corner
you had to have a wide repertoire and
you had to know what to play and when
some songs were intimate something you
had to shout to be heard by listening to
all the early folk artists and singing
the songs yourself you pick up the
vernacular you internalize it you're
singing it in the ragtime lose work
songs Georgia sea shanties Appalachian
ballads and cowboy songs
you hear all the finer points and you
learn the details you know what it's all
about taking a pistol out putting it
back in your pocket whipping your way
through traffic talking in the dark you
know that stager he was a bad man
and if Frankie was a good girl you know
that Washington is a boudoir town and
you heard the deep pitched voice of John
the Revelator and you saw the Titanic
sink in a boggy creek and your pals at
the wild Irish roller and the wild
cowboy you heard the muffled drums and
the fights that played lowly you've seen
the lusty Lord Donald sticker mention
his wife's and a lot of your comrades
have been wrapped in white linen I had
all the vernacular down I knew the
rhetoric none of it went over my hand
the devices the techniques of secrets
and mysteries and I knew all the
deserted roads that travel down to I
could make it all connect and move the
current of the day when I started
writing my own songs of folk lingo was
the only vocabulary that I knew and I
used it well that's something else as
well
I had principles and sensibilities in an
informed view of the world and I had had
that for a while
learned it all in grammar school Don
Quixote a Ivanhoe Robinson Crusoe
Gulliver's Travels Tale of Two Cities
all the rest typical Grammar School
reading they gave you a way of looking
at life an understanding of human nature
and a standard to measure things by I
took all that with me when I started
composing lyrics and the themes from
those books work their way into many of
my songs either knowingly or
unintentionally I wanted to write songs
unlike anything anybody ever heard and
these themes were fundamental specific
books that have stuck with me ever since
I read the way back in grammar school I
want to tell you about three of them
Moby Dick all Quiet on the Western Front
and the Odyssey
Moby Dick is a fascinating book a book
that's filled with scenes in high drama
and dramatic dialogue the book makes
demands on you
the plot is straightforward the
mysterious captain Ihab Kevin with a
ship called the Pequod and egomaniac
with the pegleg pursuing his nemesis the
great white whale Moby Dick who took his
leg and he pursues him all the way from
the Atlantic around the tip of Africa
and into the Indian Ocean he pursues the
way around both sides of the earth it's
an abstract goal nothing concrete a
definite he calls Moby the Emperor sees
him as the embodiment of evil a haves
got a wife and child back in Nantucket
that he reminisces about now and again
you can anticipate what will happen the
ship's crew is made up of men of
different races and any one of them who
sights the whale will be given the
reward of a gold coin a lot of zodiac
symbols religious allegory stereotypes a
have encounters other waiting vessels
presses the Kevins for details about
movie have they seen him there's a crazy
prophet Gabriel on one of the vessels
and he predicts a Habs doom says Moby is
an incarnate of a shaker God and that
any dealings with him will lead to
disaster he says that the Captain Ahab
another ship's captain captain bloomer
he lost an arm to Moby but he tolerates
that and he's happy to have survived he
can't accept they have lust for
vengeance this book tells how different
men react in different ways to the same
experience a lot of Old Testament
biblical allegory Gabriel Rachel
Jeroboam
build on Elijah pay you names as well
Tashtego flask
daggoo fleece Starbuck Stubb mother's
Vineyard
the pagans are Idol worshipers some
worship little wax figures some wooden
figures some worship fire the Pequod is
the name of an Indian tribe Moby Dick is
a seafaring tale one of the men the
narrator says call me is now somebody
asked him where he's from he says it's
not done on any map
two places never are Stubb gives no
significance to anything says everything
is predestined Ishmael has been on a
sailing ship his entire life calls the
sailing ships he has Harvard and Yale he
keeps his distance from people but
typhoon hits the Pequod Captain Ahab
thinks it's a good omen Starbuck thinks
it's a bad woman considers killing a ham
as soon as the storm ends a crew member
falls from the ship's mast and drowns
foreshadowing was to come a quaker
pacifist priest who is actually a
bloodthirsty businessman
tell flask some men who received
injuries are led to God others are led
to bitterness everything is mixed in all
the myths the judeo-christian Bible
Hindu myths British legends st. George
Perseus cookies there are whalers Greek
mythology the gory business of cutting
up a whale lots of facts in this book
geographical knowledge whale oil Goods
the coronation of royalty noble families
in the whaling industry whale oil is
used to anoint the Kings history of the
whale phrenology classical philosophy
pseudo scientific theories justification
for discrimination everything thrown in
and none of it highly rational highbrow
lowbrow chasing and losing chasing death
the great white whale where does a polar
bear what is a white man the Emperor the
nemesis the embodiment of evil the
demented Kathryn who actually lost his
leg years ago trying to attack
with a knife we see only the surface of
things we can interpret what lies below
any way we see fit kou man walk around
on deck listening for mermaids and
sharks and vultures follow the ship
reading skulls and faces like you read a
book here's a face I put in funnier
readin if you can test ego says he died
and was reborn his extra days are gift
he wasn't saved by Christ though he says
he was saved by a fellow man and a
non-christian as that he parodies the
resurrection when Starbuck tells a head
that he shall let bygones be bygones
the angry captain snaps back speak that
to me a blaspheming man I'd strike the
Sun if it insulted me a hab too is a
poet of eloquence he says the path to my
fixed purpose is laid with iron rails
where my soul is grooved to run or these
lines all visible objects are both
pasteboard masks quotable poetic phrases
that can't be beat finally I have spots
Bobby and the harpoons come out boats
are lured a halfs harpoon is embedded in
blood Bovie attacks a halfs boat it
destroys it next day he strikes movie
again boats are lowered again Moby
attacks Ahab's boat again on a third day
another boat goes in more religious
allegory he is risen
Moby attacks one more time ramming the
Pequod and sinking it a hab gets tangled
up in the harpoon lines and is thrown
out of his boat into a watery grave its
rail survives he's in the sea floating
on a coffin and that's about it that's
the whole story that team and all that
it implies would work its way into more
than a few of my songs All Quiet on the
Western Front was another book that did
All Quiet on the Western Front is a
horror story this is a book where you
lose your childhood your faith in a
meaningful world and your concern for
individuals you're stuck in a nightmare
sucked up into a mysterious whirlpool of
death and pain you're defending yourself
from elimination
you're being wiped off the face of the
map once upon a time you were an
innocent youth with big dreams about
being a concert pianist
once you loved life and the world and
now you're shooting it to pieces day
after day the hornets bite you in words
laughs your blood you're a cornered
animal you don't fit anywhere the
falling rain is monotonous this endless
assaults Pleasant gas nerve gas morphine
burning streams of gasoline scavenging
and scabbing for food
influenza types us dysentery life is
breaking down all around you in the
shelves I'm whistling this is the lower
region of Hell mud barbed wire rat
filled trenches rats eating the
intestines of dead man trenches filled
with filth excrement someone shouts hey
you there stand and fight who knows how
long is nestled on warfare has no limit
you're being annihilated and that leg of
yours is bleeding too much you killed a
man yesterday and you spoke to his
corpse you told him after this is over
you'll spend the rest of your lives
looking after his family who's profiting
here the leaders in the generals gained
fame and many other prophets on mentally
but you do the dirty work
one of your comrades says wait a minute
where are you going and you say leave me
alone I'll be back
then you walk out into the woods of
death hunting for a piece of sausage you
can't see how anybody in civilian life
is any kind purpose at all
oh they're worries all the desires you
can't comprehend it more machine guns
rattle more pots of bodies hanging from
wires more pieces of arms and legs and
skulls where butterflies push on teeth
more hideous wounds puffs coming out of
every pore lung rooms wounds too big for
the body gas blowing cadavers and dead
bodies making retching noises death is
everywhere nothing else is possible
someone will kill you and use your dead
body for target practice boots too
they're your prized possession but soon
they'll be on somebody else's feet
there's froggies coming through the
trees merciless bastards your cells are
running out it's not fair to come at us
again so soon you say one of your
companions is laying in the dirt and you
are take them to the field hospital
someone else says you might save
yourself a trip what do you mean turn
him over you'll see what I mean you wait
to hear the news you understand why the
war isn't over
the Army is so strapped for replacement
troops at the drafting young boys who
are little military use but to draft
them anyway because we're running out of
man sickness and humiliation and bilk in
your heart you would betrayed by your
parents your school masters your
ministers and even your own government
the general with the slowly smoked
cigars you to turn you into a thug and a
murderer if you could you'd put a bullet
in his face the commander as well you
fantasize that if you had the money you
put up a reward for any man who would
take his life by any means necessary
and if he should lose his life by doing
that then let the money go to his ass
the colonel too with his caveat as
coffee he's another one spends all his
time in the officers brothel you'd like
to see him stone dead two more Tommy's
and Johnny's with their whack for my
daddy-o and their whiskey of the jaws
you kill 20 of them and 20 mole will
spring up in their place it just stinks
in your nostrils
you've come to despise that older
generation that set you out into this
madness into this torture chamber all
around you your comrades are dying dying
from abdominal wounds double amputations
shattered hip bones and you think I'm
only 20 years old but I'm capable of
killing anybody even my father if he
came at me yesterday you tried to save
her who didn't messenger dog somebody
shouted don't be a fool
one froggy is laying gurgling at your
feet you're stuck in with a dagger in
his stomach but the man still lives you
know you should finish the job but you
can't you're on the real iron cross and
a Roman soldier is putting a sponge of
vinegar to your lips months passed by
you go home on leave you can't
communicate with your father
he said he'd be a coward if you don't
enlist your mother to on your way back
out the door she says
you be careful of those french girls now
more madness you fight for a week or a
month and you gain 10 yards and then the
next month it gets taken back all that
culture from a thousand years ago that
philosophy that wisdom Plato Aristotle
Socrates what happened to it it should
have prevented this your thoughts turned
homework and once again you're a
schoolboy walking through the tall
poplar trees it's a pleasant memory more
bombs dropping on you from blimps you
got to get it together now you can't
even look at anybody for fear of some
miscalculate there are no other
possibilities then you notice the cherry
blossoms and you see that nature is
unaffected by all this poplar trees the
red butterflies the fragile beauty of
flowers the Sun you see how nature isn't
different you at all all the violence
and suffering and mankind Nature doesn't
even notice it you're so alone then a
piece of shrapnel hits the side of your
head and you're dead you've been ruled
out crossed out you've been exterminated
I've put this book down and closed it up
I never wanted to read another war novel
again and I never did Charlie Poole from
North Carolina had a song that connected
to all this
it's called you ain't talking to me and
the lyrics go like this I saw a sign in
the window walking uptown one day join
the army see the world is what it had to
say you'll see exciting places with a
jolly crew you'll meet interesting
people and learn to kill them too oh you
ain't talking to me you ain't talking to
me I may be crazy and all that but I got
a good sense you see you ain't talking
to me you ain't talking to me killing
with a gun don't sound like fun you
ain't talking to me
The Odyssey is a great book whose themes
have worked its way into the balance of
lotta songwriters
homeward bound green green grass of home
home on the range and my songs as well
the Odyssey is a strange adventurous
tale of a grown man trying to get a home
after fighting in a war he's on that
long journey home and it's filled with
traps and pitfalls he's cursed to wander
he's always getting carried out to sea
always having close calls huge chunks of
boulders rock his boat he angers people
he shouldn't
there's troublemakers in his crew
treachery his men I turned into pigs and
then they're turned back into younger
more handsome men he's always trying to
rescue somebody he's a traveling man but
he's making a lot of stops he's stranded
on a desert island he finds deserted
caves and he hides in them he meets
Giants and say I'll eat you last and he
escapes from Giants he's trying to get
back home but he's tossed and turned by
the winds Restless winds chilly winds
unfriendly winds he travels far and then
he gets blown back he's always being
warned of things to come touching things
he's told not to there's to Rosa Teague
and they're both bad both hazardous on
one you could drown and on the other you
could starve he goes into the narrow
streets with foaming whirlpools that
swallow him meat six headed monsters
with shock fangs
Thunderbolts strike at him overhanging
branches that he makes a leap to reach
far to save himself among raging river
goddesses and gods to check in but some
others want to kill him he changes
identities he's exhausted he falls
asleep and he's woken up by the sound of
laughter he tells his story to strangers
he's been gone 20 years he was carried
off somewhere and left there drugs have
been dropped into his wine it's been a
hard road to travel in a lot of ways
some of these same things have happened
to you you two have had drugs dropped
into your wine you two have shared a bed
with the wrong woman you two have been
spellbound by magical voices sweet
voices with strange melodies you two
have come so far and have been so far
blown back and you've had close calls as
well you have angered people you should
not have now you two have rambled this
country all around and you've also felt
that he'll wind the wind that blows you
no good and that's still not all of it
when he gets back home things on any
better scoundrels have moved in an hour
taking advantage of his wife's
hospitality and there's too many of them
and though he's greater than the mall
and the best of everything
best carpenter best hunter best expert
on animals best seaman his courage won't
save him but his trickery will call
these stragglers we'll have to pay for
desecrating his palace he'll disguise
himself as a filthy beggar and a lowly
servant kicks him down and steps with
arrogance and stupidity the servants
arrogance revolts him but he controls
his anger he's won against a hundred but
they'll all fall even the strongest he
was nobody and when it's all said and
done
when he's home at last he sits with his
wife and he tells us the stories so what
does it all mean myself and a lot of
other songwriters have been influenced
by these very same themes and they could
mean a lot of different things if a song
moves you that's all that's important I
don't have to know what a song means
I've written all kinds of things into my
songs and I'm not going to worry about
it what it all means
when Melville put all his Old Testament
biblical references scientific theories
Protestant doctrines and all that
knowledge of the sea and sailing ships
and whales into one story I don't think
he would have worried about it either
what it all means John Donne as well the
poet priest who lived in the time of
Shakespeare wrote these words the
cistal's and a by toes of her breasts
not of two lovers but two loves the nest
I don't know what it means either but it
sounds good and you want your songs to
sound good when Odysseus in the Odyssey
visits the famed warrior Achilles in the
underworld Achilles who treated a long
life full of peace and contentment for a
short one full of honour and glory tells
Odysseus it was all mistake
I just died that's all there was no
honor no immortality and that if he
could he would choose to go back and be
a lowly slave to a tenant farmer on
earth rather than be what he is a king
in the land of the dead that whatever
his struggles of life were they were
preferable to being here in this dead
place and that's what songs are to our
songs are alive in the land of the
living
but songs are unlike literature they
meant to be sung not read
the words in Shakespeare's plays were
meant to be acted on the stage just as
lyrics and songs I meant to be sung not
read on a page and I hope some of you
get the chance to listen to these lyrics
the way they were intended to be heard
in concert on record or however people
are listening to songs these days I
returned once again to Homer who says
singing me old mutes and do me tell the
story
you